i grew up as a working-class guy and
when i started investing in property i
thought everyone would say that's
fantastic you provided affordable houses
for people but they didn't everyone said
you're taken away from first-time buyers
you're taken away from the poor by you
monopolizing the property industry i
thought okay fair enough and i got into
property development i started building
houses from scratch i'm like how can
they argue with that man bringing
bringing a problem to the shortage
massive shortage of houses i'm now
building houses uh but but you know what
people said people said oh you're
building them too small you're greedy
developer you know trying to squeeze all
the profit look at these small little
houses that you build in and now i'm
building big beautiful houses i'm
building luxurious properties and guess
what people are now saying they're
saying um
millionaire
building luxury houses for other
millionaires what about us i tell you
what about you
stop relying on me to pay your food
that's what